long delayed movie sequels worst idea
ever or just the worst idea of the
century find out on this before we start
you should go follow me on Twitter an
angry nerd wired you can witness a
blistering Twitter Throwdown I had with
this guy Chris Baker about whether it's
wrong for me to hate on all prequels
this handsome but slow with it
individual is trying to argue that
classics like Godfather two and x-men
first class of prequels sorry one
of those is a hybrid prequel sequel and
the other is a reboot so they do not
count as evidence in favor of prequels
anyway enough about prequels let's get
stupid so I'm watching the trailer for
the new Jim Carrey movie and it's
stirring up distant memories of a movie
that I dimly remember enjoying two
decades ago I dug around in the Attic I
still have a copy
dumb and dumber
oh geez this was due back at Hollywood
Video in 1996 it's gonna kill me why
does his sequel leave me so cold
I love the Farrelly Brothers and they're
extremely logical style of humor sorry
did I say logical I meant scatological
and I savor the chance to see Jeff
Daniels take a break from all that
pompous speechifying on the newsroom
to embrace his inner dolt
but come on Dumb and Dumber to really
should have appeared around the time of
the Monica Lewinsky scandal
not now it is missed its historical
moment with sequels we have to strike
while the iron is hot just look at Sin
City then to kill Warren it's shaping up
to be the biggest bomb of 2014 that's
probably because nine years have elapsed
since the first citizen a sequel would
have been hotly anticipated if it had
appeared in say 2006 but by now that
anticipation has gone as cold as the
glare of a White Walkers mother-in-law
when a movie appears so long after the
last entry in a franchise you can tell
that no one involved really had a
burning desire to continue this story
from the original the sole motivation to
make it was clearly something else can't
quite put my finger on it
anyway consider that all of these recent
sequels appeared more than a decade
after the last entry in the series and
they all left me wondering if they were
really worth the wait seeing that list
it's just a little bit harder to work up
any excitement for the forthcoming
Jurassic world or even Star Wars VII now
long delayed sequels aren't uniformly
terrible they can work when they don't
try to just paper over the time delay
but address it directly in a way that
resonates see Toy Story 3 was worth the
11-year wait because it was about the
passage of time we see children becoming
adults we see the toys passed on to a
new generation of children and the 1986
film Color of Money was a worthy
follow-up to the 1959 classic The
Hustler because it had Paul Newman
dealing with the same sort of cocky
young guy that he portrayed in the first
film
looking a little Tom Cruise I just want
to pinch his cheek and warned him to
never ever ever jump on a couch may be
dumb at number two will my new forms of
hilarity from the special dilemmas that
morons face as they become parents and
enter middle age I I want to believe boy
but how can i I've seen Godfather three
I've seen the two Jakes see the better
the original is the tougher it is for
the long-delayed sequel to live up to on
its own terms
psycho two it was a decent B movie but
stacked up against the greatest horror
film of all time it's just pathetic it
could have been twice as good and it
still would have seemed unworthy ah
actually the fact that Dumb and Dumber -
isn't a timeless masterpiece might
actually bode well for this sequel see
it has a lot less to live up to banned
psycho - did I mean let me know in the
comments if you disagree but to my mind
Dumb and Dumber pales beside the
Farrelly Brothers brilliant Kingdom what
now that movie was a flawless jewel with
a million facets
kingpin - would be a sacrilege what
1990s movie would you like to see get a
sequel make your case down in the
comments and I'll critique your
arguments oh let me stress it long
delayed sequels are only bad in movie
land long delayed TV reboots like the
recently announced twin Pink's are great
I'll finally learn what happens in the
White Lodge I'm hoping the Twin Peaks
show-within-a-show an invitation to love
gets a reboot within a reboot oh and
check out my collaboration with Battle
Damage they graciously agreed to destroy
an object of my choosing
are you excited let me know in the
comments and be sure to subscribe to the
wired Channel